[Musique]
où se trouve le plus puissant dans notre
usine ce serait l'atelier celui qu'on
les 10 nouveaux employés de l'usine de
fromage d'agropure à Granby sont tous
Ukrainiens du métro père de famille
arriver en avril et parmi eux ce jour-là
il achève sa formation certificat en
main il est prêt à travailler dans
l'usine et rêve déjà dit devenir
opérateur
pour nourrir illoger sa famille de métro
a eu quelques boulots temporaires depuis
son arrivée motivé et enthousiaste il
est apprécié par son nouvel employeur
c'est une naturelle pour agrouper
ici au Québec d'accueil des travailleurs
dans leur dans nos usines c'est même une
très grande source de fierté comme vous
savez on a une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
ici au Québec faites une solution à cet
enjeu là
la fille de Demi trou Dominica est en
premier année à l'école du Pélican à
Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu son intégration
scolaire se passe très bien
une joie de vivre une force de caractère
incroyable on pourrait vraiment pas
deviner tout ce qu'elle a vécu tout ce
qu'elle a laissé derrière elle est-ce
que tu connais le nombre qui vient juste
après 19
bravo c'est fait de bonnes amies elle
communique par des phrases simples mais
elle a vraiment appris plusieurs mots du
vocabulaire de la langue française
est-ce que tu l'aimes ta professeur
la rejoint chaque jour à la sortie des
classes puis elle marche vers la maison
située juste à côté
[Musique]
Oxana occupe un poste de femme de
chambre dans un hôtel de Saint-Jean le
temps de mieux apprendre le français
violent
presque tout ce qu'ils ont dans leur
appartement leur a été donné grâce au
couple qui les a hébergés pendant leurs
deux premiers mois au Québec
[Musique]
Dominica l'ouverture et l'empathie des
Québécois les a d'ailleurs aidés dans
les moments plus difficiles
bienvenue
une étape à la fois dioxana pour qui le
plus important et que sa fille soit loin
l'Ukraine mon plan est simple à prendre
le français et trouver un bel emploi en
administration
de leur année et l'arrivée au Québec en
octobre de la mer et du beau-père de
demi-tour qui sont passés ce soir-là ils
habitent maintenant à Saint-Jean eux
aussi
têtiana mais mon cœur est déchiré entre
le Canada avec mon fils et l'Ukraine ou
ma fille habite toujours ce qu'il trouve
tous le plus difficile ici c'est la
barrière de la langue et aussi l'accès à
un médecin nous sommes un sourire si on
a besoin d'un rendez-vous c'est presque
impossible d'en voir eux rapidement
contrairement à l'Ukraine difficulté
l'Ukraine qui tous les jours continue de
les inquiéter du métro pensent
constamment à ses proches encore là
malgré des hauts et des bas ils sont
contents d'être ici
[Musique]